is on her feet and home secretary's on
her feet uh let's listen in I would like
to make a statement about the
government's illegal migration bill
two months ago the Prime Minister made a
promise to the British people
he said that anyone entering this
country illegally will be detained and
swiftly removed no no
half measures
the illegal migration bill will fulfill
that promise
it will allow us to us to stop the boats
that are bringing tens of thousands to
our Shores in flagrant breach of both
our laws and the will of the British
people
now the United Kingdom must always
support the world's most vulnerable
since 2015
we've given Sanctuary to nearly half a
million people
these include 150 000 people from Hong
Kong 160
000 people from Ukraine 25
000 Afghans fleeing the Taliban
indeed my own parents
indeed my own parents Mr Speaker decades
ago found security and opportunity in
this country something for which my
family is eternally grateful
crucially these are decisions supported
by the British people precisely because
they were decisions made by the British
people and their elected representatives
not by the people Smugglers and other
criminals breaking into Britain on a
daily basis
for a government not to respond to waves
of illegal migrants breaching our
borders would be to betray the will of
the people we were elected to serve
now the small boats problem is part of a
larger global migration crisis in the
coming years developed countries will
face unprecedented levels with pressures
from ever greater numbers of people
leaving the developing world for places
like the United Kingdom
unless we act today the problem will be
worse tomorrow and the problem is
already unsustainable
Mr Speaker people are dying in the
channel
the volume of illegal arrivals has
overwhelmed our Asylum system the
backlog has ballooned to over a hundred
and sixty thousand the Asylum system now
costs the British taxpayer three billion
pounds a year
since 2018
some 85 000 people illegally entered the
United Kingdom by small boat 45
000 of them in 22 2022 alone
all traveled through multiple safe
countries in which they could and should
have claimed Asylum
many came from safe countries like
Albania
almost all passed through France the
vast majority 74 in 2021 were adult
males under the age of 40 Rich enough to
pay criminal gangs thousands of pounds
for passage
upon arrival most are accommodated in
hotels across the country costing the
British taxpayer around 6 million pounds
a day
the risk remains that these individuals
just as appear
and when we try to remove them they turn
our generous Asylum laws against us to
prevent removal
the need for reform is obvious and is
urgent
this government has not sat on its hands
Mr Speaker
since this prime minister took office
recognizing the necessity of joint
Solutions with France we've signed a new
deal providing more technology and
embedding British officers with French
Patrols and I hope Friday's anglo-french
Summit will further deepen that
cooperation
we've created a new small boat
operational command with over 700 new
staff
we've doubled NCA funding to tackle the
smuggling gangs we've increased
enforcement raids by 50 we've signed a
deal with Albania which has already
enabled the return of hundreds of
illegal arrivals and we're procuring
accommodation including on Military land
to end the farce of accommodating
migrants in hotels
but let's be honest it's still not
enough in the face of today's global
migration crisis yesterday's laws are
simply not fit for purpose
[Music]
and de facto opened
opens through unlimited safe and legal
routes as the alternative let's be
honest there are a hundred million
people around the world who could
qualify for protection under our current
laws
let's be clear they are coming here
we've seen a 500.
we've seen a 500 increase in small boats
Crossings in two years and this Mr
Speaker is the crucial point of this
bill
they will not stop coming here until the
world knows that if you enter Britain
illegally you will be detained and
swiftly removed
[Applause]
removed back to your country if it's
safe or to a safe country a safe Third
Country like Rwanda
and that is precisely what this bill
will do that is how we will stop the
boats
with that Mr Speaker this bill enables
Detention of illegal arrivals without
bail or judicial review within the first
28 days of detention until they can be
removed it puts a duty on the Home
Secretary to remove illegal entrants and
will radically narrow the number of
challenges and appeals that can suspend
removal
only those under 18 medically unfit to
fly or at a real risk of serious and
irreversible harm and exceedingly High
bar in the country we are removing them
to will be able to delay their removal
any other claims will be heard remotely
after removal
when our modern slavery Act passed the
impact assessment envisaged 3500
referrals a year
last year 17
000 referrals took on average
543 days to consider
modern slavery laws are being abused to
block removals
that's why we granted more than 50 of
Asylum requests from citizens of a safe
European country and NATO Ally Albania
that's why this bill disqualifies
illegal entrance from using modern
slavery rules to prevent removal
Mr Speaker I won't address the Bill's
full legal complexities today some of
the Nations some of the nation's finest
legal Minds have been and continue to be
involved in its development but I must
say this rule 39 and the process that
enabled the Strasbourg Court to block at
the last minute flights to Rwanda after
our courts had refused injunctions was
deeply flawed
our ability to control our borders
cannot be held back by an opaque process
conducted late at night with no chance
to make our case or even appeal
decisions
[Applause]
[Music]
we've initiated disc USS in Strasbourg
to ensure their blocking orders meet a
basic natural Justice standard one that
prevents abuse of all 39s to thwart
removal
and it's why the bill will set out the
conditions for the UK's future
compliance for such orders
other countries share our dilemma and
will understand the justice of our
position
our approach is robust and novel which
is why we can't make a definitive
statement of compatibility under section
19 1B of the Human Rights Act
of course the UK will always seek to
uphold international law and I am
confident that this bill is compatible
with International obligations
and when we stop the boats Mr Speaker
the bill will introduce an annual cap to
be determined by Parliament on the
number of refugees the UK will settle
via safe and legal routes
will ensure an orderly system and
considering local Authority capacity for
housing public services and support
so to conclude Mr Speaker the British
people are famously a fair and patient
people
but their sense of fair play has been
tested Beyond its limits and they've
seen the country taken for a ride
their patience has run out
the law-abiding patriotic majority have
said enough is enough
[Applause]
this cannot and will not continue their
government this government must act
decisively must act with determination
must act with compassion must act with
proportion
so make no mistake this conservative
government this conservative prime
minister will act now to stop the boats
and I commend the statement to the house
[Applause]
[Music]